-These days, the news stinks.
I don't have to tell you that.
Every headline I see makes me
feel worse than the last.
Every once in a while,
there's a story
that makes me feel great.
And I'd like to share one
in a segment called
"The Kind of Story
We Need Right Now."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a Eurasian eagle-owl,
but it's not just any
Eurasian eagle-owl.
This owl's name is Flaco,
and last month,
he was minding his own business,
living in the Central Park Zoo,
when some vandals
cut a hole in his enclosure.
And Flaco did what any
self-respecting owl in captivity
would do -- he escaped.
That's right.
Flaco Shawshanked
out of that cage, which...
[ Laughter ]
...according to one article,
was the size of a bus stop
and which he'd been living in
for 12 years,
and he started flying
around Central Park.
This is the kind of story
we need right now.
Every New Yorker dreams
of moving out of their tiny
[Bleep] apartment,
into a nicer neighborhood,
and Flaco did it.
Every New Yorker wants to live
on Central Park?
Suddenly, this dude was living
in Central Park,
without a trust fund.
Incredible.
Also Flaco had been living
next to the penguin enclosure,
and if there's one thing
every New Yorker
has had to put up with
at some point,
it's living next to somebody
who eats a ton of fish.
My man Flaco
escaped a nightmare.
[ Laughter ]
Not long after Flaco
left the zoo,
he was spotted on 5th Avenue,
peering in the window
at Bergdorf Goodman.
Of course he was.
He spent 12 years
living in Manhattan,
never got to see the sights.
[ Laughter ]
That's why he was also spotted
at the Statue of Liberty,
at the M&M's store,
and in the front row
at "Hamilton."
There he is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Probably a montage of him
somewhere,
trying on a bunch of outfits.
Flaco's escape created
an exciting opportunity
for him to spread his wings.
But more importantly,
it created an opportunity
for reporters to say owl puns.
-It's a hoo-dunnit.
-Hoo-dunnit.
-Hoo-hoo-hoo-dunnit.
[ Light laughter ]
-It's a "How did you not come up
with something
better than that?"
[ Laughter ]
I love that they don't even
come up with different puns.
It's like they're all using
the same copy
of "Bartlett's Puns
for Reporters."
But the best part
of this whole story is,
everybody underestimated Flaco.
When he first escaped,
an owl expert
told "The New York Times"
that Flaco
would be easy to catch,
because in his experience, owls
were not particularly smart.
Oh, yeah?
Then why are they
the only birds who graduate?
[ Laughter ]
Authorities were worried
Flaco wouldn't be able
to feed himself in the wild,
because he'd spent
his whole life in captivity.
Well, guess what owls eat?
Rodents and birds.
Worrying an owl will starve
in Central Park
is like worrying a toddler
will starve
in a chicken-nugget factory.
[ Laughter ]
Flaco did just fine on his own
because Flaco's not a dumbass,
but zoo officials were still
determined to get him back.
So they set up
an elaborate ruse.
They left a dead rat
out in an open field,
and they put it inside a trap.
And then they played a recording
of owl mating calls
to lure Flaco to it.
And you know what happened next?
Flaco swooped down,
grabbed the rat,
but didn't stay long enough
to get caught in the trap.
But he did stay long enough
to look directly at a camera...
[ Laughter ]
...and pose.
Look at his face.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know Flaco,
but I'm pretty sure
that face is saying, "Do I look
like a [ bleep ] idiot?"
[ Laughter ]
The zoo officials are like,
"We shouldn't tell anybody
about this."
[ Light laughter ]
They made several more attempts
to catch Flaco.
They followed him around
Central Park with nets.
The NYPD even tried to catch him
with a dog crate.
Nothing worked.
And pretty soon,
New Yorkers started putting
pressure on officials
to just leave Flaco alone.
And after weeks
of trying to catch him,
zoo officials did just that.
They announced they would end
their attempts to capture Flaco,
and let him be free.
This is the kind of story
we need right now.
Everyone underestimated Flaco.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They said he couldn't survive
on his own.
He did it.
This is a story
for the underdogs,
a story for anybody
who's ever been told,
"You're too short
to play basketball,"
or "Girls can't do math,"
or "J.Lo is never gonna date you
a second time."
So, tonight, if you walk
through Central Park,
look up at the sky.
You just might see
something amazing.
You might see
Flaco flying free,
with a rat from one talon
and a "Hamilton" playbill
in the other,
'cause this is the kind of story
we need right now.
[ Theme music plays ]